je le lirai stylo rouge en ce2 quand
j'étais en classe il y avait des
personnes qui avait pas de fournitures
et il se compter par le prof
bah moi je regrettais je voulais aider
plus de gens
[Musique]
on est allé voir notre prof est une île
accepté pour qu'on passe temps les
classes ans ma mère elle n'était pas au
courant des accusés acquittés
donc je perdais tout le temps dans les
affaires elle s'est rendue compte en
trois petits bugs dans mon sac
il était marqué votre crâne il ne jetez
plus vos stylos pour sa suivi n'ont rien
[Musique]
voilà on a reçu sa country
on est fier de cette idée déjà au départ
et puis de l'investissement aussi que
victor est capable de donner tout le
long parce que c'est vrai que ça demande
beaucoup de temps on soit des cartons
foulée trier faut prendre du temps pour
quand on fait des manifestations x ou y
passer du temps pris souvent c'est le
temps du week-end c'est le seul jeu seul
le moment de la semaine on a le droit de
jouer aux jeux vidéo donc il faut
accepter de donner de sa personne et de
son temps
[Musique]
on en a même donné au centre social
là ce sont des écoles qui nous ont donné
des manuels enfin des spécimens en fait
qu'ils reçoivent pour pour faire leurs
cours et en fait on en a on en a eu pas
mal et on a commencé à en donner
notamment pour les centres sociaux qui
font de l'aide aux devoirs ou qui font
des actions d'alphabétisation à une
association là sur l'île qu'on a aidé
dernièrement donnant des livres
justement de ce type pour faire là aussi
des cours d'alphabétisation auprès
notamment de la pop idol populations de
migrants donc
donc ça c'est des outils très très
précieux cela c'est vrai que c'est un
peu jeune et c'est pas l'âge qui compte
on peut être jeune et faire une
association c'est normal parce que il y
en a qui ont besoin d aide
ça me fait du bien de penser que y est
pas qu il ya des gens qui sont
maintenant ça nous enrichit en tant
qu'être humain quand on arrive à être
dans une dynamique dead
donc ce que je pourrais passer comme
message c'est effectivement pas avoir
peur quoi d'aidé et je suis on a peur de
lancer sa propriété menthe pas hésiter à
se renseigner sur les associations qui
existent et pourquoi pas de faire plein
de petits bébés feutre et compagnie ça
nous ferait plaisir aussi
c'est un grand classique de dire ça
n'est merci à tous ceux qu'il donne qui
vont donner ou qui ont donné et ben
[Musique]
merci encore